to some breaking news out of the United
States now when the U.S military has
just released video of the encounter
between Russian su-27 fighter jets and a
U.S drone there has been a growing war
of words between Moscow and Washington
over a U.S drone that crashed in the
Black Sea in a phone call Russia's
defense minister told his U.S
counterpart that drone flights near
Crimea were provocative
earlier the U.S said the aircraft was
intentionally harassed by a Russian
fighter jet but it wasn't sure if the
Collision was deliberate well let's get
more on this now we're joined by Samir
Puri he's a visiting lecturer in war
studies at King's College London he's
also the author of Russia's road to war
with Ukraine and he's joining us from
Singapore always good to have you with
us on Al Jazeera so what do you make of
this video
well it's a very dramatic footage and I
think it gives us images that accompany
the words that we read yesterday or the
day before in the Department of Defense
press release explaining what had
happened uh we see the fuel being dumped
by the Sukhoi 27 Russian fighter we see
it of course pass extremely close to the
US Reaper drone and then we lose a foot
surgeon and the footage comes back and
then we also uh I think another
important detail is since yesterday
we're discussing this is actually you
have more of a sense of where in the
Black Sea this went down south west of
of the Crimean Peninsula so I think
we're starting to put the picture
together a little bit more clearly as to
what happened and where this drone was
actually flying when this encounter took
place okay so so far the video confirms
what U.S officials have been saying but
can it reveal whether the encounter was
intentional
based on on how I've interpreted the
footage I don't think so and I I think
if the Russian pilot intended to
physically knock out this drone as in
you know fly so close that it actually
touched his own aircraft that is an
extremely risky maneuver for that pilot
because it's you know millimeters or
centimeters away from the mid-air
Collision so I still think on balances
may have been something the Russians
were doing to pass very closely to
demonstrate of course that they want to
show that they have Mastery over these
Skies the America Americans can't fly
these intelligence mites undisturbed uh
but I I don't think it's possible
necessary to distinguish whether it was
intentional or accidental
and the Americans You know despite
condemning what's happened the language
that they've been using around this
incident is one of saying that it was
incompetence on the part of Russians
rather than them trying to do anything
like this intentionally
yes that's right and I think of course
the Americans uh are going to be
principally concerned as to their future
of flying these intelligence gathering
missions these surveillance missions
which you know the southwest of the
Crimean peninsula where we know this
drone went down that's more or less
below Odessa uh the Ukrainian city that
was you know threatened it's not far
from where the muscover Russian warship
was sunk back in April so I think
there's there's a big concern in the US
that they'll be able to continue to
mount these surveillance operations uh
without this kind of thing happening
again so that's the other big U.S
concern and what about concern over the
debris is anyone looking for it what
happens if it's found how difficult is
it to find debris
um in the Black Sea
right well uh so as we understand it
again it's a very deep part of the Black
Sea so the surveillance operation will
be extremely complicated uh some sort of
critics of Russia have have quipped that
the Russians struggled 20 years ago to
actually get the Kursk submarine their
own submarine when it went down in a
torpedo propulsion uh uh accident how
are they going to find it at the same
time there have been reports of Russian
warships coming to where that that
wreckage is Sergey lavrov the Russian
foreign minister said that they're going
to try to recover it uh we'll wait and
see whether they do recover it uh but if
they do that might be quite a benefit to
to the Russians and also probably to the
Iranians who they're in a drone
partnership with as we know Russia buys
Iranian drones maybe they would Supply
the technology a readout of that
technology on the American drone to the
Iranians in the quote that's a
possibility if they get it back it's
very interesting Mr poodie thank you for
your time as always that is Sameer for
rejoining us live from Singapore